Ist das auch noch Teil des Intros gerade, oder? Ich glaube schon. Und jetzt kommt das Intro. Jetzt kommentieren sie den Anfang, der oft nach Intros einsetzt. Aber es ist jetzt so viel Meta-Ebenen, dass ich gar nicht mehr weiß, wie ich darauf reagieren soll. Aber vielen Dank. Und jetzt viel Spaß bei der Folge. Den der der der der der der hier ist das Podcastfo. Ist das jetzt noch das Intro gewesen? Das war das Intro. Hast du schon gesprochen? Ich dachte, ich improvisiere heute mein eigenes Intro. Hallo, herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe des DPU-Podcasts. Mir gegenüber natürlich Stefan Enzo Ticicciotti. Hallo, herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen Folge des Podcast-Ufo. Mein Name ist Stefan, das ist Florentin, der die ganze Zeit redet. Ich frage, ob wir jetzt, er hat auch gesungen gestimmt, ob jetzt, Rezitativ ist das. Er hat auch rezitiert, ob jetzt ein Circle, so genannt Full Circle erreicht ist, ein Full Circle Moment. Ich würde sagen, wir hören mal ins Intro rein. Okay. Leider Jazz. Das, ach so, ich dachte Fanfare. Ne, leider, leider Gottes Jazz. Leider Gottes Jazz. Manchmal geht man ja in ein Musiklokal rein, weiss gar nicht, was gespielt wird. Leider Jazz. Gut, die Bar hieß Leider Jazz. Leogen Jazz und dann dachte ich, ideal für mich die Liebesfalle aufzuziehen, also schaue ich mal in München in eine Jazz-Parte. Aber ich finde es so gut, dass du offensichtlich so verzweifelt warst, dass du zum einen jemanden daten wolltest, die auf Jazz steht, obwohl du es hast. Alle Red Flags. Du hast das, alle wissen, dass du es hast. Es gibt einen berühmten Jazz-Klassiker, der heisst Red Flags.
Und da geht es darum, dass wenn jemand Jazz hört, alle rote Flaggen hochgehen.
Also es ist wirklich kommunistisches China.
Hören wir mal kurz rein.
Was soll das heissen, du verlässt mich?
Weil du nur Jazz im Kopf hast. Bass Solo. Er hat die Tropäne mittlerweile weggelegt. Es ist einfach, es ist Naked Jazz, die neueste Interaktion. Oh, das ist so gut, Naked Jazz. Wann geht's mal voran im Jazz-Business? Wir haben jetzt Chicago Blues. Blablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablablabl Das war aber vor vier Jahren. Keep it up! Keep it up! Baden-Baden-Jazz, warum gehen wir nicht mal richtig rein in die neue Jazz-Sorte, in die neue Vanilla-Jazz? Jetzt, diese Folge kommt ja am ESC-Samstag raus für die Peasants. Ihr werdet sie wahrscheinlich gar nicht hören, weil ihr den ESC konsumiert, damit es nicht die Escape-Taste gemeint, obwohl man bei manchen ESCs durchaus gerne auf selbige drücken würde, um endlich rauszukommen aus dem Laptop, um dann den ESC anzugucken, um dann auch auf der Fernbedienung auch ESC zu drücken, um dieses leidige Thema endlich den Chaos zu machen. Ich liebe das Thema, ich liebe den Contest. Die Klubbetrieieder können das jetzt vor dem Contest noch hören. Ihr kennt das von uns, wir gehen heute jeden einzelnen Teilnehmer durch. Wir machen ESC-O-Rat. Welcher ESC-Teilnehmer repräsentiert euch am meisten? Was mir beim ESC fehlt, ist so ein Handfester-Skandal. Fehlt, sorry, ich habe das überhaupt nicht verstanden. Was mir beim ESC fehlt, ist so ein Handfester-Skandal. Jetzt habe ich den Anfang nicht verstanden. Was mir beim ESC fehlt, ist ein Handfester. Jetzt habe ich den Anfang nicht verstanden. Was mir beim ESC fehlt ist ein Handfester-Skandal. Oh, gab's zuhauf? Nee, so ein richtiger Tonja Harding, der hat mir die Stimmbänder durchgeschnitten vorm Auftrag. Irgendwie wirklich mal so, ja, der hat mir irgendwie Laxenta-Schock ins Wasser reingemischt, dass ich den Auftritt versau oder oder sowas, Bolivien. So Uhu-Stift an die Steppschuhe. Genau sowas, weil ich sag mal so, beim ESC nehmen jetzt nicht nur hundertprozentig demokratisch gefestigte Nationen teil. Ich schau niemanden an. Italien, ich schau niemanden an. Ich schau niemanden an, Bella Italia. Aber es gibt ja da auch Länder, die, sag ich mal, im militärischen Bereich bereit sind, durchaus auch eine Grenze zu übertreten. Wer? Nenn mir einen. Was hast Lennendea gesagt? Jetzt weltpolitisch ist es ja, sag ich mal, jetzt kein, es ist ein offenes Geheimnis. Gut, wir gehen mal durch. Russland ist nicht dabei, Belarus, soweit ich weiss, auch nicht dabei. Syrien? Gibt's, glaube ich, auch nicht mehr. Persien auch nicht dabei. Hat sich leider politisch ehrenboden. Nee, du hast recht. Es gibt Länder. Ich schau niemanden an. Ich schau nicht. Also da gibt es einige Länder, die wirklich auf dem Index stehen. Und die, finde ich, auch jetzt mal Hand anlegen könnten und bereit sein könnten für so einen handfesten Skandal, den man dann wiederum fünf Jahre später aufklärt. Aber seien wir ehrlich, ohne Skandale sind die meisten Veranstaltungen nicht so super interessant. Letztes Jahr hat hinter den Kulissen der holländische Kandidat, den man geschlagen oder so, weiss man nicht so genau, und wurde dann disqualifiziert. Oh, vor oder nach seinem Auftritt? Weit davor. Er durfte gar nicht erst teilnehmen. Guck mal, das ist langweilig. In den Proben ist was passiert. Na ja, komm. Nee, sowas sollte während der Punkteverteilung stattfinden. Punkteverteilung … Oh, wir hören gerade, der Holländer hat der Armenierin ins Gesicht gespuckt. Okay, wir wollten gerade Barbara Schoeneberger am Brandenburger Tor. Nochmal, wir wollten gerade, wir wollten gerade, Ralf Schmitz, wir wollten gerade Holland 24 Punkte geben. Taut Guido Kanz auf. Okay, taut jetzt, wir drücken den Knopf. Jetzt wird Guido Kanz aufgetaut. Das wäre noch mal ein Moment, dafür könnten wir Guido Kanz auftauen für den ISC. Ich merke, dass du bist, wie sicher bist du der 24 Punkte? Baller ist der Song von A, Bo und Tinner, glaube ich, weiss ich nicht genau, ob ich den Namen jetzt verhunzt habe. Österreicher, die würde da schon antreten. Das hat ja gut geklappt in der Weltgeschichte. Da bitte ich schon mal irgendwie so ein, ja genau, entweder so etwas ganz Furchtbares oder so ein trojanisches Pferd. Und dann auf der Bühne singen die nicht, weil die, weil die, weiss nicht, zumindest wollen, dass Deutschland nicht vor Österreich ist oder so. Verstehe, aber für Österreich treten auch Österreicher an oder da dann Schweizer? Für Österreich ist Schweizer. Okay, wir machen das Rondell. Der Dachraum hat sich einmal rotiert. Das Dachrondell, okay, einmal rum.
Es ist super interessant, weil es war ja dieses Jahr, es ist ja auch immer das Politikum, weil es ja immer der NDR wählt ja in so einer fragwürdigen Runde aus, während die Vorauswahl kommt und dann darf man abstimmen und zwischen Not und Elend darf man sich entscheiden und dann kommt irgendwer wieder hingeschickt. Und Europa wundert sich immer, dass aus dem grössten Land, was teilnimmt beim ESC, sowas kommt. So, jetzt hat es ja aber wieder Stefan Raab in die Hand genommen. Er hat sein großes Comeback gefeiert. Sternchen, die sind dann jetzt wieder abgesetzt worden. Aber in der Zwischenzeit hat er es noch geschafft, in diesem kleinen Fenster, was er hatte, konnte er zumindest den neuen ESC-Kandidaten, die Kandidatinnen suchen. Was ja eigentlich ein guter Move war, also das war ja vielleicht von Anfang an sein Ziel, dass er sagt so, dieses ganze TV-Comeback ist eigentlich alles nur eine Blendgranate. Genau. Und es war blendend. Es war hell, grell. Dass wir wirklich auf der anderen Seite hole ich mir den ESC nochmal unter die Fuchtel, um den langsam den kalten, toten Clown des NDR zu entreissen. Genau. Finde ich gut. Der NDR war immer noch beteiligt, ich glaube, das wird man auch nicht los, weil das Rennste ist ja ein EBU, also ein Zusammenschluss auch irgendwie bei der öffentlich-rechtlichen Seite, was auch immer. Und da hat Stefan Raab es ausgetragen, hat die beiden gefunden und die jetzt losgeschickt mit dem Song Bala. Okay, wo ist Lena? Kann man die auftauen? Also kann man die nicht noch mal ins Gemetzel werfen? Lena ist, glaube ich, seit 2012, war sie nicht mehr gesehen. Aber muss man ja sagen, Stefan Rappmann kann über seine Karriere sagen, was man will, aber er hat uns wirklich nach vorne gepeitscht beim ESC. Und würde das sein Comeback perfekt machen, wenn wir jetzt noch mal gewinnen würden beim ESC, würdest du dann sagen, er ist offiziell zurück? Ja, ich weiß nicht, ist nicht die Raab-ESC-Zell jetzt auch vorbei. Also ich finde, da können immer andere Leute was. Also der NDR soll das mal einfach jetzt auch der Stefan Raab wieder wegnehmen und dann soll sich jemand anders kommen und sich in diesem, weißt du, dem Dieb beklauen. Also es muss ein anderer kommen, muss sich diesen zwischen die, weil die beiden sind streiten, die streiten ein Riesen. Und da kann jetzt so ein kleiner,
so eine David-artige Figur
kann jetzt den beiden Goliaths, die
hier nur nachkämpfen, ich ändere das ab, es gibt zwei
Goliaths in dieser Lore und
muss das wegnehmen. Ja, apropos
Diebstahl, wir haben eine Mail bekommen von unserem
Rechtsbeistand, ist kein Rechtsbeistand,
Hashtag, ist kein Rechtsbeistand, wir haben
trotzdem eine Mail von ihm bekommen. Ja.
Zum Thema, darf man stielen?
Das war Thema in der
Vielen Dank dafür, unser Kontaktformular wird reichlich genutzt und wir haben auch Lob bekommen zum Thema Kontaktformular.
Ein IT-Sicherheitsexperte meinte, das sei unglaublich nützlich, solche Kontaktformulare, weil wir haben ja geungt, dass es quasi das gleiche ist wie eine Mail.
Ja, aber Formulare sind eigentlich einfach eine Mail, aber der IT-Sicherheitsexperte meinte, nee, das ist viel besser, weil du musst deine E-Mail-Adresse nicht öffentlich auf einer Webseite schreiben und damit kann die auch nicht von irgendwelchen Bots gefunden werden, die dann in irgendwelche Listen stecken. Dafür können uns die ganze Zeit Bots schreiben. Ich weiss nicht, ob Bots schlau genug sind, um Kontaktformulare zu benutzen, ob die da einfach so dagegen laufen wie so ein Saugroboter. Du unterschätzt Bots schon so lange. Ja, komm mal, Saugroboter hat mich nicht überzeugt. Saboron, der die Goblins, wie es die Hobbits, die Hobbits unterschätzt hat. Gerade stimmt. Ich habe nichts gelernt von diesem Film. Die Bots von Mittelerde. Aber zum Thema, ja also, um das abzuschliessen, IT-sicherheitstechnisch ist es eine gute Sache, einen Kontaktformulat zu haben. Unser Jurist aus Lübeck schreibt uns zum Thema, darf man stehlen? Und er schreibt, der Diebstahl, also nein. Also es ging darum, Florentin hat mal wieder gelogen, und das ist jetzt die Podcast-UFO, Richtigstellung, Richtigstellung, Ellung, Ellung, Ellung, Ellung, Ellung, Ellung, Ellung. Weil Florein hat behauptet, da liegen doch Belagen, nämlich in deinem Fall, Joghuretten aus der Packung gefallen einzeln auf dem Boden. Du hast gesagt, lose Ware kann ich nehmen. Die sind ja gar nicht zum Einzelverkauf gedacht. Mein Gegenargument war, du kannst ja nicht die Regale im Supermarkt einfach so mitnehmen. Nicht alles, was da nicht niederlagelfässig ist. Genau, worauf ich finde, wie er das Argument gebracht habe. Ja, worauf ich gesagt habe, fick dich. So, und ich habe in meiner Argumentation versucht, häufig den Begriff lose Ware zu verwenden. Ja, es klang so, als wäre es ein rübeles Wort. Genau, in der Hoffnung, dass das ein juristischer Terminus Maximus ist und ein Jurist dann sagen würde, wow, krass, dass Florentin den Begriff lose Ware kennt, das ist nämlich genau ein Ausnahmefall, da habe ich mich leider ein wenig vertan. Du hast ja darauf spekuliert, das mache ich auch häufig, dass Juristen auch nicht genau alle Paragraphen auswendig können. Und du natürlich mit so geplänkeltem Fachwissen, was gar keins ist, aber es gibt dieses gefügelte Wort, es gibt es suggeriert, dass du irgendwie mehr Wissen hast. Ein anderer Tipp für mir wäre, dass du einen Fall zitierst. Wie bei zum Beispiel Darmstadt gegen Leibniz. Genau. Oder Familie Sünder gegen Lidl. Genau, Deutschland gegen und dann irgendwie Falkner, die Falkners. Das deutsche Volk gegen die Falkners. Familie Sünder aus Köln. Gegen Ulrike Sönner aus Lübeck. Ja. Und ja, also da schreibt unser Jurist aus Lübeck, schreibt, der Diebstahl ist gemäss, ne ne ne ne. Nein, er hat gesagt, tatsächlich liegt hier, in Klammern anders als Florentin das sagt, ein strafbarer Diebstahl vor, weil du hast ja die Joghurette mitgenommen. Sagen wir lustig in der Anekdote. Der Diebstahl setzt die Wegnahme einer fremden und beweglichen Sache voraus. Ich verschone euch mal mit den Definitionen dieser Tatbestandsmerkmale. Brauchst du nicht, also kann man durchaus orientierlich gehen. Jedoch liegt hier völlig unstreitig ein Diebstahl vor. Wichtig, im Gegensatz zum Betrug setzt ein Diebstahl auch keine Vermögensschäden voraus. Ich muss nochmal lesen, wichtig, im Gegensatz zum Betrug setzt ein Diebstahl auch keinen Vermögensschaden voraus. Also der Baum, der, der, der Supermarkt macht ja keinen Vermögensschaden,
weil die diese Joghörte eh nicht mehr verkaufen können.
Das ist aber egal.
Das ist egal.
So, wohingegen bei Betrug, also das heisst, wenn ich bei Betrug niemandem schade, Gofford. Ja, oder guckt einen Film oder so. Floridin kann sich auch nicht darauf berufen, dass er nicht wusste, dass er einen strafbaren Diebstahl begeht. Verdammt. Das ist ja vor Strafe schützt, wie heißt das nochmal? Genau, Dummheit, Saubermheit, schützt vor Strafe nichts. Dieser Irrtum war nämlich vermeidbar. Ja, aber welcher Irrtum ist nicht vermeidbar? Rückblickend, das kannst du immer gut sagen, rückblickend hätten wir auch zu einem Irrtum und fliegen sollen. Aber manchmal hat man einfach einen Blasen. Es wäre Florentin ohne Probleme möglich gewesen, dies herauszufinden, zudem wäre das eine Situation auch von Florentin zu erwarten gewesen. Menge zu erwarten. Okay, aber jetzt verstehe ich nicht, warum er da jetzt so Seitendiebe austeilt. Aber, bla bla bla, der Diebstahl wird geringwertiger Sachen grundsätzlich nur auf Antrag erfolgt. Ja, weil wir immer diese Paragraphen da auslassen wollen und der Satz dann aber keinen Sinn mehr gibt. In diesem Fall wäre daher ein Strafantrag des Supermarktinhabers erforderlich gewesen, ja, wo kein Kläger, kein Richter. Du kannst auch einfach... Das geht ja nicht immer, ja, ja, genau. Aber das heißt, Betrug, wenn kein Schaden vorliegt, darf man auch... Aber das stimmt doch nicht, oder? Also jetzt mal angenommen, wir sagen, hey Leute, ganz coole Sache, und zwar verlosen wir zwei Fiat Punty in dieser Folge das Podcast UFO unter allen Leuten, die in unserem Reddit kommentieren. Der Betrug sieht folgendermassen aus, machen wir nicht, die Autos sind nicht in unserem Einflussbereich. Jetzt denkt alle Leute, ach geil, cool, ich kann teilnehmen an diesem Wettbewerb, kommentieren, kommentieren, kommentieren, wir machen gar nichts, niemand wird denken, fuck, ich habe kein Auto gewonnen, die betrügen und am Ende hat niemand Schaden, also ist es nicht strafbar? Können wir einfach ein Gewinnspiel vortäuschen, bei dem wir nie überhaupt die Intention haben, etwas zu verlosen, weil es kommt ja niemand zu schaden.
Ich glaube, hier gilt wieder der Satz, alle Angaben sind wie immer ohne Gewehr und der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen, weil das haben wir ja gelernt, bei Gewinnspielen, der Rechtsweg ist ausgeschlossen, zu sagen hilft ja bei Gewinnspielen, weil sozusagen bei uns ja, ich weiß nicht mehr, wie das ausdrückt wurde, ganz toll wurde es formuliert, wir bieten Leuten was an und dann gibt es da so Leute, die was erwarten und dann … Genie. Also wir verlosen dieses in dieser Folge zwei Fiat Punti unter allen Leuten, die uns ein Intro schicken. Ja. Viel Spaß, viel Glück. Ja, aber dann fließt ja Zeit rein, sozusagen.
Ja, aber ist Zeit ein Schaden?
Ja, kein Vermögen ist ja ein Zeitschaden. Ja, Zeitschaden, wir können es nicht mit Zeitschaden machen. Aber du... Also eine Frage, dürfen wir unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer in dieser Form betrügen, wie zum Beispiel Adrian, der hat uns das Intro zur heutigen Folge gesteckt, und da hören wir jetzt mal rein. Ja, und dann dementsprechend kriegt Florentin jetzt, also musst du jetzt den Fiat Punto besorgen, einen Fiat Punto besorgen? Jeder besorgt einen Fiat Punto und wir gucken, wer ihn billiger kriegt. Einfach noch mal als Neben-Challenge. Nächste Folge berichten wir euch, wie das passiert ist. Wir können machen, was wir wollen, wir können lügen und lügen und lügen. Niemand kann uns was, weil kein Schaden entsteht.
Gut, aber vielen Dank auf jeden Fall an unseren Hausjuristen aus Lübeck. Vielleicht einfach, vielleicht eine Katze, die auf die Tastatur tippt. Wir wissen es nicht, wer dahinter steckt, aber aktuell unser offizieller Rechtsbeistand. Ja, vielen Dank. Du hast geklaut. Was ich immer noch nicht, ich bin immer noch gedanklich bei deiner These, wo du behauptest hast, dass der Vorsatz wichtig ist, was man in dem Moment dachte, man ist nicht immer noch so bescheuert, weil dann geht es ja immer nur theoretisch über Gerichtsfällen müsste es darum gehen, herauszufinden, wie sehr derjenige den Straftat begangen hat, das in dem Moment wollte. und man kommt immer ganz, ganz einfach da, nee, sagt nicht ja, als wäre das die Realität.
Das ist nicht die Realität. Man versucht herauszufinden, war es oder war es nicht und nicht, was hat er dabei gedacht. Klar geht es darum, ob es vorsätzlicher Mord war. Ja, genau. Ich glaube, da geht es dann wirklich nur noch um dieses, ist es Mord, Totschlag oder eins von den drei Brüdern da. Aber ich glaube, Stress hast du so oder so.
Du hast so oder so wirklich, sage ich mal, die Kacke an den Schuhen, juristisch gesprochen. Ja. Ob es jetzt Mord oder Totschlag ist, Lirum Larum, Löffelstiel. Lirum Larum, nullens wohlens, Lirum Larum. Dafür hast du einen Anwalt, so, der Anwalt, der klümmelt das aus, so. Aber für dich ist das ja erst mal nicht so geil. So, das ist dann irgendwie so, ja, ich habe einen Stein vom Balkon geworfen, habe zufällig den Liebhaber meiner Frau getroffen, war das jetzt Vorsatz oder nicht? In dem Moment war ich gar nicht sauer. Ich wusste es nicht. Also dann machen die ihre Juristereinummer da so, keine Ahnung. Heisst aber auch, wenn ihr immer Gutes denkt, dann kann euch auch nichts, dann kann euch niemand was. Oder wenn ihr gar nichts denkt, also wenn ihr wirklich leer seid. Bei Vorsatz setzt ja voraus, dass überhaupt irgendwas vorhanden ist, dass überhaupt eine geistige Kraft, überhaupt nicht institutional. Also dann seid ihr auf der sicheren Seite, wenn ihr erstmal nichts denkt. Ja. Wer nicht denkt, der nicht straft. Ja, ja. Nee, aber ich habe geklaut, tatsächlich gebe ich zu, ich werde aktuell noch nicht verfolgt. Was sie ja mittlerweile machen, es wird ja warm, es wird ja warm. Ich bin kein Freund der Wärme. Ja, auch nicht. Und deswegen baue ich tatsächlich mir immer elaborierte Pläne, um möglichst gut mit der Wärme umgehen zu können. Zum Beispiel, ich bin, ich hole mir ab und zu eine Packung Schokoküsse im Supermarkt. Aber jetzt ist warm, Schokoküsse haben nun eine winzige Schokoladenmembran, die wirklich innerhalb von drei Sekunden durchgeschmolzen ist. Das ist crazy. Wir reden jetzt nicht von einem Riesen oder so, wo du wirklich Permaschokolade hast, wo du die 20 Minuten im Auto liegen lassen kannst und du hast auf jeden Fall noch eine harte Schicht Schokolade vorhanden. Schokoküsse ist ja wirklich winzig klein. Und was ich deswegen mache, ist, wenn ich einkaufen gehe, gehe ich sofort zu den Schokoküssen, nehme mir eine Packung und lege die ins Eisfach, zu den Flutschfingern. Das, du hast schon mal Kinderbuehne oder Kinderriegel oder sowas … Kinderriegel habe ich auch schon mal …
Aber da denke ich, du musst aufhören, den Supermarkt zu behandeln, als wäre dein persönliches Wohnzimmer. Ja, aber warum denn nicht? Ja, warum nicht? Also ich meine, wenn ich rausgehe, ich meine, ich verzehre die eh auf dem Parkplatz. Also ich bin wirklich … Das ein bisschen so ein Äquivalent wäre, ich schleppe so eine gemütliche Couch in so einen Saturn und setze mich da von Fernseher.
Ja, im Grunde schon.
Ich weiss nicht.
Benutz die Waren des Warenhauses fürs persönliche Vergnügen.
Genau.
Deinen Mehrwert.
Oder wenn du so in so einem Baumarkt bist und du nimmst dir so einen schönen Sessel und trägst den ins Restaurant, wo man beim Obi essen kann und geniess deine Currywurst in diesem Sessel, trägst den dann wieder runter in die Sesselabteilung und gehst nach Hause. Du wolltest nur eine Currywurst essen mit dem Sessel. Ist das erlaubt? Also darf ich innerhalb eines Ladens … Nimmst ein Brett mit einem Nagel drin in den Obi und Du nimmst da einen Hammer vor Ort und ein paar Ballastchen reingehst raus und dann kannst du stehen die und sagen, bitte was? Ja, richtig. Ich nehme Stücke meines Rasens mit zu Obi, nimm da den Rasenmäher, rass da drüber und dann gehe ich wieder, lass den Rasenmäher stehen. Was sind die Grenzen? Was darf ich alles innerhalb eines Supermarkts tun? Vor allem, ich durfte neulich klauen. Wir hatten es schon in den letzten Folgen erzählt, ich habe gerade so eine Heimwerkerphase, ich heimwerke viel und, oh Gott, Foti hat sich sein Ellenbogenknochen angestossen. Oh nein, hey, hey, hey, hey, alles gut. Ich habe gelernt, man muss Kinder einfach nur ablenken. Hier, hier, zack, hier hast du einen Kaffee. Und ich bin auch, wir müssen organisieren und aufräumen zu Hause. Und jetzt habe ich so viele so Kisten, in denen ich Sachen verstaue und so ganz ordentlich wegpacke in meinem so Abstellraum. Wir wissen, was das für ein Projekt ist. Nee, nee, wie gesagt, ganz viele Projekte. Ich will wissen, was das für ein Projekt ist. Ganz viele Projekte. Warum sagst du uns das nicht, was das für ein geheimes Projekt ist? Nein, nein, es ist langweilig, aber es sind viele Projekte. Es sind viele Lampen, die ich baue selber, Regale, die ich baue, aber eben auch, ich bin einfach gerade so ein Heimwerker-Guy. Eine Steckdose hast du verlegt. Ich habe auch aus dem Lichtschalter eine Steckdose gemacht. Aber das ist jetzt dunkle Magie. Ich weiß finde ich, hört Heimwerken auf und da beginnt Hexerei. Weil das geht nicht, dass du aus einem Formwandeln, es ist kurz davor. Auf einem Einfluss habe ich einen Abfluss gemacht. Das geht nicht. Ich habe aus einer Tür, wo man reingehen kann, eine Tür gemacht, wo man rausgehen kann. Weißt du, was ich bald mache, was ich bald wirklich mache? Aus einem Abluftschacht wird ein Klimaanlagenschacht. Leute, ich kenne gar nichts mehr. Ich habe aus einem Licht ein Gerät gemacht, das Dunkelheit verspeut. Einfach umgelebt. Ich merke nur gerade, die da oben, die da oben, die wollen einem suggerieren, dass man das alles selber gar nicht kann und man muss für alles Handwerker haben. Braucht man nicht. Braucht man nicht. Wirklich nicht.
Brauche ich schon. Nee, das ist ja gerade mein Punkt. Brauchst du nicht. Das haben die da oben eingetrichtert mit den Chemtrails. In deinem Gehirn, die Radiowellen, die 5G-Strahlung. Die Handwerker sitzen da dahinter. Ob die es konkret jetzt sind, weiß ich nicht. Die freuen sich. Wenn deine Beschwerungszirke 20 Jahre alt ist, die vier ...
Ich hab fünf hier gesagt, aber wir nehmen den Witz gerne mit. So, und dann war ich da, habe vor Jahren mal schon so eine Organisationsbox gekauft, aber ohne Deckel. Und jetzt sehe ich da im ... Dann wollte ich da für immer einen Deckel haben und sehe dann, die Geschichte ist egal.
Und dann wollte ich einfach da und dann wollte ich diesen Deckel mitnehmen, sehe, ah, den hätte ich damals schon kostenlos mitnehmen können, weil diese Deckel sind bei den Kisten dabei, man kann sich einfach einen Deckel mitnehmen, die sind nicht, die kann man nicht kaufen, ähnlich, ähnlich analog zu seinem Joghuretteding, seinem einzelnen. Also bin ich damit dann zu so einer Information gegangen und habe gesagt, kann ich das mitnehmen? und die haben gesagt, nee, wir verkaufen das einzelne.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe das damals mal gekauft.
Streng genommen ist jetzt hier, das liegt jetzt hier mein Deckel noch rum.
Sie haben einen Deckel im Plus.
Nein, habe ich nicht. Hin und her, ich war sehr nett und dann haben die mir das gesagt, ja, nimm das einfach mit raus, wir rufen an der Kasse vorne an und sagen denen Bescheid.
Ich natürlich gedacht, das so als sportliche Challenge genommen, weil wir ja auch öfter überlegen, wie gut, da gibt es nämlich auch so Self-Checkout-Kassen in diesem Bauhaus. Und ich dachte, wie gut komme ich da jetzt, kriege ich das raus. Weil jetzt ist ja gewisserweise, wenn die mich erwischen, sage ich, ja, die wollten doch hier anrufen, weißt du? Das war so gewisserweise jetzt so ein Planspiel. Okay, ein Verbrechen ohne Gefahr. Ja, ein Betrug ohne, genau, ein Plan, ja, oder was ich am Anfang gesagt habe, ein Planspiel. Und dann bin ich da raus und habe dann alles gescannt, außer diesem, diesen Ding. Und dann kam die Verkäufer und hat gesagt, was haben Sie denn da? Wow, crazy. Durchsichtiger Deckel? Durchsichtiger Plastikdeckel. Durchsichtiger Plastikdeckel, und wer wurde er spät? Was ist das denn für Augen? Naja, er ist riesig gross. 25x25, das hätte er wieder. Ist das so gross? Also, du hast so einen grösseren Deckel gesehen. Ja, das ist unlieb. Das heisst, eigentlich, es herrscht der Deckel-Unbalance jetzt in diesem Baumarkt, oder? Aber jetzt ein Deckel? Nee, es stimmt wirklich, die Geschichte stimmt wirklich. Ich habe damals da wirklich... Du hast den Deckel zurückgelassen? Einen Deckel zurückgelassen, nur die Kiste. Und jetzt aber, als du da warst, hast du dann auch einen Deckel mehr vorgefunden? Oder hast du von einer anderen Kiste den Deckel? Nee, die Deckel sind … Das ist gar nicht der Fokus der Geschichte. Die Deckel sind separat. Eins separat daneben, ja. Aber ich dachte mir, holy shit, das ist schon a risky business.
Ja, ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und nicht so klar, dass man damit durchkommt. Von daher würde ich euch raten, komm, das einfach sehr bezahlen und dann noch Trinkgeld geben. Ich war letztens Sonntag in der Nähe eines Baumarkts und ich mag das ja immer ganz gern. Ich auch.
Gerade so Gewerbegebiete, wo mehrere Mediamarkt, Baumarkt oder so sind dann alle da zusammen und grosse Parkplätze, die so alle in und und und und das sonntags, wo dann irgendwie so Leute mit ihrem ferngesteuerten Auto da auf dem Parkplatz sind. Die brauchen mal so einen grossen Asphaltbereich oder so Kinder mit so Rollern und Inlineskates. Ja, oder so Kinder, die von den Eltern Autofahren beigebracht bekommen. Ja, habe ich auch gesehen, ja genau. Und wo dann irgendwie, das ist so wie die Natur nimmt sich diesen Parkplatz wieder so und so diese Menschen, die kommen dann einmal in der Woche raus.
Mit Natur meinst du den fängstörten Tesla. Genau, ja, es ist eine Art von Natur.
Und da habe ich gemerkt, dass vor dem Baumarkt einfach das komplette Sortiment, das normalerweise vor dem Baumarkt liegt, also ich rede von Erde, so Geröllsteine, so Säcken, die liegen einfach immer noch vorm Baumarkt. Du kannst einfach hingehen und dir so einen Sack Blumenerde nehmen, der liegt einfach offen sonntags vorm Baumarkt. Das scheint so egal zu sein oder so aufwendig zu sein. Oder Leute, die Blumenerde brauchen, klauen das nicht. Also mein Instinkt hat sofort gesagt, nimm alles mit, aber es ist halt einfach so ein 60-Gibliothekerer Geröll. Sack. Menschen, die Blumenerde in ihrem Leben brauchen, sind finanziell, glaube ich, schon so gut gestellt, dass sie es nicht klauen müssen. Ja, stimmt schon. Und du gehst, glaube ich, auch nicht auf Raubzug, um jetzt die Blumenerde zu holen oder so. Aber technisch gesehen hätte man das alles mitgeben können. Klar, du sagst, überwacht oder sowas in der Richtung. Aber mich hat das beeindruckt, wie viel da noch ist, wie viel nicht zurückgenommen wird. Vielleicht ist der Aufwand, das zurückzuräumen, grösser als der finanzielle Schaden, der mal aufkommt, wenn die Sinners die Blumenerde mitnehmen. Für mich hat das das Produkt total entwertet. Blumenerde? Ja, dass jemand sagt so, ähm, sorry, wollen wir das nicht noch irgendwie einsperren übers Wochenende? Und die so, pff, nee. Es kostet 5,99 Euro, so ein Sack Blumenerde, das ist jetzt auch
nicht super billig. Ich als der Hersteller
dieser, meinetwegen Gartenstühle,
die dann da rumstehen, würde auch
sagen, Entschuldigung, warum steht meine
Gartenstühle eigentlich die Sonntag noch draußen?
Die sind scheißegal, die sind uns scheißegal.
Die will eh niemand, die klaut
niemand. Das ist ein Familienbild,
wir machen seit 1925,
100-jähriges, wir machen wirklich Gartenstülle die ganze Zeit. Nee, selbst wenn es kostenlos ist, nimmt das keiner mit. Mein Urgrossvater hat schon dieses Familienunternehmen gegründet. Nee, den kannst du komplett in die Tonne klopfen. Ich bin jetzt in dritter Generation, mache ich jetzt dieses Unternehmen und wir machen diese Gartenstülle mit Liebe. Wir sind ein kleiner Betrieb, okay. Machen sich keine Sorgen, die klaut kein Mensch, die klaut kein Mensch. Wir tragen teilweise die Leute wirklich direkt auf dem Parkplatz, können die direkt mitnehmen, macht kein Mensch. Die lassen die liegen. Selbst die Vögel, die hier kommen, die picken hier schön das ganze Zeug weg, die Stühle lassen die liegen, völlig egal. Ja, die können auch keine Stühle mitnehmen, die sind hier so klein. Wie, was ist das für ein Argument? Das ist vielleicht ein schlechtes Beispiel. Ja, das ist ein schlechtes Beispiel. Baumarkt-Mitarbeiter, ich habe jetzt nicht die besten Beispiele einfach so rumgegeben. Aber jetzt denke ich mir, das hat sich jetzt irgendwie entlarvt. Jetzt denke ich mir, ah okay, Sie können einfach meine Schülle nicht wertschätzen. Vielleicht haben Sie recht. Was haben Sie für geilen Schülle zuhause? Ich habe diese super billigen Billo-Plastik-Stülle, die habe ich geklaut vom Ofen. okay, vielleicht haben wir recht. Aber ich fand das, ich fand das Eindruck, ich habe tatsächlich jetzt eine Woche gehabt, möchte ich ehrlich sein, ich reisse mir gerade mein Inneres raus, ich werfe dir meine Gedärme ins Gesicht, so ehrlich bin ich gerade, ich hatte eine Woche der Warenentwertung. Du hättest nicht gedacht, dass ich so weit gehe. Ich hätte nicht, dass der Satz da schon vorbei ist. Du hättest nicht gedacht. Wiederholen Sie mal. Du hattest eine Woche der Warenentwertung. Genau, ihr kennt das Podcast-Ufo als wirklich ein Hamidami-Halligalli-Podcast. Hamidami-Hamidami-Hamidami-Halligalli-Podcast. Wo man mal irgendwie wirklich sich die rote Nase aufsetzt. Nee, ich lasse wirklich jetzt mal auch die Hose runter und gehe mal ins Inneres. Weil ich war diese Woche in einem Restpostladen, Restpostenladen, wo man alles kaufen kann, was woanders niemand wollte. Und irgendwie wird es dann so umkontextualisiert. Genau. Und das ist dann einfach so, hier findest du, es ist ein Riesenladen, wo nur Dinge drin sind, die niemand will, aber halt richtig billig. Und irgendwie fasziniert mich das total. Weil du merkst so, das ist so wie so eine Art Waisenhaus irgendwie so, wo so die Verlorenen, die haben keine Heimat und da sind auch willkürliche Produkte einfach nebeneinander. Und waren da jetzt schon durch Trumps Zölle dadurch irgendwie schon so krasse Sachen? Nee, aber auch aus aller Welt. Also sowas, was in Rumänien niemand will, wird dann da noch verschachert. Und das ist einfach so ein ganz merkwürdiges Ökosystem, wo du reingehst und da gibt es ganz merkwürdige Produkte. Da hast du dann so einen Plastiksack mit Rohwurstenden. Und da muss ich erstmal kurz stehen bleiben und dachte, Moment, Rohwurstenden. Also du hast, erstmal hast du Rohwürste und die werden anscheinend in Scheibe geschnitten. also vielleicht sowas wie Salami oder so, wo du so geschnitten im Supermarkt kannst du die geschnitten kaufen, aber du verkaufst nicht die Enten. Ist Salami eine Rohwurst? Die gekocht, ich weiß nicht genau. Wie Bratwürste zum Beispiel? Ich weiß nicht, ich weiß nicht genau, was eine Rohwurst ist, aber anscheinend werden die dann geschnitten und die Enten bleiben übrig und die werden dann da verkauft als Reste. Und das hat für mich so eine ganz eigene Faszination. Rohwurst ist ein Wursttyp, die Basis bildet Rohwurst, das heißt nicht erhitztes Fleisch, also unten haben wir zum Beispiel Salami, Brühwürste, Nicht Brühwürste, nicht, nee, nicht, eben nicht Brühwürste, sorry, Feldkiker, Krakauer, Salami, Schinkenwurst, genau, Thüringer Knackwürste, die Plockwurst, die Mettwurst, die Kohlwurst, die Dürre Runde, ne, wir kennen das, Dauerwurst, die Dauerrohwurst, die Stemaro,, Bauernsäufzer, Westfählinger, die sind Bauernsäufzer, Cabernossi halt, ne? Kielbassa, Rohdezipreziner, Landjäger, Knackwurst, Westfählinger, der Globus dreht sich in Hochgeschwindigkeit gerade, wo sind wir gerade, Italien, Spanien, dann wieder Depreziner, dann wieder die Stuttgarter Wulsen. werden. Das gilt auch für Lebensmittel mit einem Anteil an rohen Innereien von Schweinschaf oder Wild. Auch bei Rom mangelhaft erhitzt zum Fleisch und anderen Tieren bestehende Infektionsrisiko. Jesus Christ, der Debbie-Downer-Absatz. Was soll das denn? Hepatitis E? Wir waren doch gerade bei Cabanossi und Pfannen und unserer Rohwurst. Was ist denn da so ein Downer? Ja, klar, ein Auto kann mich auch totfahren. Ja, okay. Hier war jetzt in den Artikel von Auto. Ja. Hepatitis E, also wie viele Hepatiten gibt's denn eigentlich, also wenn das bis E geht? E ist ein Buchstabe, wo man wirklich schon nachdenken muss, der wievielte das ist, ne? Fünf. Also es gibt, aber ja, fünf, okay. A, B, C, D, E. Ja, muss man schon nachdenken. Fünf. Also es gibt, ab wann kannst du nicht mehr spontan sagen, der wievielte Buchstabe des Alphabets ist? Oh, ich glaube, das ist keine glatte Kurve.
Das ist eine ... Ich sag den Buchstaben, du sagst ja, wieviel ist es.
C, drei, F, sechs, G, dann sieben, H.
Du bist einfach sehr schlecht in diesem Fest, das hinzumachen.
Ja, das stimmt.
Weißt du, warum? Weil F weiss ich sofort, weil das bei den Simpsons immer die schlechte Note war von Rat. Richtig, genau. K? Keine Ahnung. Kein Schimmer, ne? Überhaupt kein Schimmer. Also ist der Punkt der Erreicht auf jeden Fall. Aber du hast Rohwurstenten auf jeden Fall, die du ja kaufen kannst. Aber die sind noch frisch. Was? Billig, billig, billig. Und vor allem das Geile ist, was du in dem Laden ganz oft findest, sind so Sondereditionen. Also zum Beispiel wusste ich gar nicht, dass es es gibt, Schokobons mit Waffel. Wo du erst mal denkst, geniale Idee. Wollte aber anscheinend niemand kaufen, so dass es alles im Sonderrestposten verschachert laden.
Bitte nimm's, sonst werfen wir es weg, laden's. Bitte nimm's. Nimm nicht Nimm zwei, sondern nimm alle einfach. Nimm so viel du willst. Und deswegen Warenentwertung, weil zum Beispiel war dann auch in der Kühlabteilung waren riesige Kisten mit Magnum Sun Chaser. Und diese Sondereditionen, die werden ja eigentlich als was super edles, als was besonderes jetzt mit Blattgold und Aprikosen-Sorbet und super besonders. Aber wenn die niemand kauft, dann landen die halt in so einem Sonderrestposten-Ding, wo du hundert sind. Du kriegst hundert Magnums für zwanzig Euro. Sind die Mitarbeiter da auch die Leute, die in anderen Supermarkt gehen wollen?
Absolut, ja. Und das ist so ein ganz merkwürdiger Laden, weil ich war dann auch an der Kasse und der Kunde vor mir hat dann auch gezahlt.
Und ein Kunde, der Hausabot hat.
Der bei Edeka rausgeflogen ist. Und dann meinte die Kassierin so, ich gehe das nächste Mal zur anderen Kasse, dann kann ich dir da noch ein bisschen Rabatt geben. Aber wenn du bei meiner eigenen Kasse bist, kann ich das nicht machen. So, die kannten sich anscheinend und haben offen am Tageslicht. Das ändert für mich aber alles, wie ich Kassen niemals wahrgenommen habe. Ja, anscheinend. Ich dachte, Kassen, die kommen dann nämlich immer, beobachtet man manchmal, weil immer genau, wenn ich dran bin, ist Kassenwechsel Dreck. Und dann kommt eine andere Kassiererin zum Beispiel, wechselt die ab, die da gerade saß und bringt dann ihre eigene Geld, Wechselgeldreserve mit. Genau, ja, ja. Das fand ich so faszinierend, weil ich dachte, ist ja nicht dein Geld, also das Geld von DM. Oder ich dachte immer, die werden danach beurteilt, wie viel Geld sie einnehmen. Die müssen dann am Ende ihrer Schicht diesen Kasten auf die Waage legen und dann so bubububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububububub Also nimmt ein guter Kassierer mehr Geld ein als ein Schlechwer? Ich glaube nicht. Eigentlich nicht, oder? Also an meinem Marsch eines guten Kassierers zum Beispiel. Aber der macht mehr Kunden pro Minute. Weiß ich gar nicht. Kann man das festmachen? Ja, das, also ich dachte nur, wenn sie sagt, in meiner Kasse kann ich das nicht. Genau. Denke ich mir, das ist ihre Kasse? Ja, anscheinend, ich dachte, ich dachte, also da können es auch nicht gehen. Weil nicht mal so ein Pilot würde sagen, das ist meine Boeing. Nee, aber auch so, ich dachte, wenn ich dir bei meiner Kasse Rabatt gebe, dann kann man es nachverfolgen. Dann kann man sagen, Moment mal, Jutta hat hier, du hast hier 80 Kilo Rohwurstenden gekauft und Jutta berechnet dir 50 Cent, die sind locker 1,50 wert. Ja, wir verkaufen Trash, wir verkaufen, das ist alles, das ist alles, warum guckt, wir verkaufen, es ist nur Trash, ob das andere nicht verkauft haben, versuchen wir noch mit Ach und Krach zu verkaufen. Warum kann meine Kasse nachverfolgen, wem ich mehr Rabatt gebe auf die eh schon spottbilligen Wurstenden? Willst du die Kasse kaufen? Ja, willst du die Kasse kaufen? Ja, willst du mal mitnehmen, sind Preissöte dran. Ja, Sitzel. Du kannst mir Geld kaufen, was niemand will. Also wo ist das her? Kolumbien. Was ist das für Geld überhaupt? Ja, Spiegel. Zerrinnt, zwischen meinen Fingern. Esstaub, Staub, Staub. Esstaub, Staub, Staub, Staub. Nichts ist echt. Aber das war ein Erlebnis, da einzukaufen. Wo gibt es das in Lagen? Es ist unfassbar. Es ist unfassbar. Ich bin da wirklich ein ganzes Stück hingefahren, weil es gibt ja manche so Läden, wo man vorbeifährt, die man auch aus Zügen sieht manchmal. So Läden, wo man denkt, was ist das für ein Laden, wer kauft da einen? Wann geht man da hin und man merkt, das sind normale Leute, die einfach sparen wollen, die da einfach mal sagen, mir ist eigentlich egal was.
Also das ist mein Ding. Wenn du jemand bist, der, sage ich mal, nicht so viel Geld hat, dann geht man gerne in so einen Laden, um zu sparen. Mein Problem ist, du weisst nicht, was du in dem Laden kaufen kannst. Weil das Sortiment ist nicht immer gleich. Also das ist eine Form von Luxus. In den Laden zu gehen und mal zu gucken, was man kauft, ist ja eine Form von Luxus. Aber es ist alles sportbillig. Also du gehst hin, um Schnäppchen zu jagen, aber dir ist egal, welche Schnäppchen, auf eine Art. Du puckst impulsiv nach Schnäppchen, was irgendwie eine Art komische, eine Art des Spans ist. Du hast noch so ein Curveball, weil die Schnäppchen, die du kaufst, sind dann die blattkult verzierten Edelmagnums. Und wenn man dann wiederum in der Wohnung von demjenigen ist, der, weil er zum Beispiel kein Geld hatte, da einkauft hat, in diesem auf eine Art Luxus verknappten Laden, bringt dann die Blattgold-Magnums mit. Und die Kinder sagen, oh, nicht wieder Magnum Sanchez, bitte nicht Mama. Das wird gegessen, was auf den Tisch kommt. Aber ein menschlicher Körper kann nur so viel Gold aufnehmen.
Oder der Vater sagt, lutscht das auf, aber das Gold schmilzen wir ein. Frau Sünder, wir mussten Ihre Tochter aus der Klasse nehmen, die hat eine Goldvergiftung. Was? Goldvergiftung gab es nur aus der nie. Aber das ist ein ganz merkwürdiges Erlebnis. Das erinnert mich auch an Arrested Development, wo die Hauptfigur Michael Bluth fährt ja immer mit diesem Treppenauto, diesem Flugzeug Treppenauto. So stelle ich mir das, also wenn die zum Beispiel ein Auto verkaufen würden, ein Fahrzeug verkaufen würden, wäre es wahrscheinlich so eine komische Karre vom Flughafen aussortiert, Swissport. Fahrrad, aber es ist ein Tandem. Aber es ist halt billiger, aber du schenkst deinem Kind halt dann Tandem, nur ein Rad zu stürteln. Genau, mein Rad war billiger. Ja, Rhönrad. Es ist ein ganz merkwürdiges, und vor allem auch immer in rauen Mengen, auch aus anderen Ländern, wo man sich denkt, so warum wird das gerade nicht verkauft? Du hast dann so zum Beispiel aus Japan, hast du dann so Mikado-Sticks, die aber eine andere Art, also du kennst ja diese Keks-Sticks mit Schokolade oder vollmich oder Zartbitter und die hast du dann aber mit Erdbeerschicht.
Kistenweise, Palettenweise und das ist das einzige Produkt aus Japan, wo entweder irgendjemand gesagt hat, okay, die sind hier super billig, die kriegen wir mit irgendwie 50 Cent pro Palette und du hast wirklich zentnerweise Spongebob-Keksticks mit Erdbeergeschmack. Und ich dachte mir so, ich nehme hier eine Packung mit. Aber niemand wird dem nicht mehr, dem Problem. Ich stelle mir so ein Industriegebiet vor, so eine Riesenhalle und dann so kistenweise, wir gucken mal, was reinkommt. Einfach Zeug. Einfach Zeug. Ich finde das fantastisch, so was, wo man auch merkt, das ist alles, was für einen Scheiss produziert wird. Ja. Alles ist fucked, es ist weird, was wir alles kaufen können und was überbleibt. Und es verschiebt sich nur so eine Kleinigkeit. Ja, ja. Wie zum Beispiel, die haben das Franchise nicht bekommen, für die, die diese Mikado-Sticks gemacht haben. Die waren eigentlich für den, weiß ich nicht, Ariel-Film oder The Brand und so und haben die das nicht bekommen. Und man merkt, das ist alles so, man hat so, guckt so, so Truman Show-mäßig, hinter den Vorhang dieser Konsumgesellschaft. Und, also ich will jetzt gar keine Namen nennen, aber da waren dann halt auch teilweise Produkte in den Laden, die man kennt. Also so aus der Werbung und so. Und man denkt sich, oh. Du gibst keinen Namen. Wie nimmst du den Schutz? Naja, ich weiß, ich finde das unfair, wenn man jetzt so callt, so. Ich habe dein Produkt in so einem Ramschladen gefunden. Ah, die verkaufen sich ja anscheinend nicht die Produkte. Das ist so eine Art andere Werbung. Ah, der Gin von Gunnar und äh. Senjordino, ja. Zentnerweise, tonnenweise. bin ich verscherbelt für 50 Cent die Pfanne. Floridtis Freunde haben mir einen Gin rausgebracht. Limoncello. Aber Limoncello, ah sorry, falls ihr sowas trinkt. Weil sonst fällt mir niemand ein, den du schützen müsstest, weil es dir leidtut. Ich finde es unfair irgendwie, wenn man da ... Leibniz ist ein riesen Konzern. Ja, okay. Aber vor allem, also das ist dann auch so, ist irgendwie ein schlechtes Image, wenn man das Produkt dann da sieht, wo man auch so so ein bisschen, schau mich nicht an, schau mich nicht an, wo du halt dann so Zentner von gewissen Produkten hast. Glaubst du, dass Firmen ihre Restposten aufkaufen oder zurückkaufen, damit sie eben nicht da landen? Interessant, vielleicht ist das sogar der tatsächliche Gewinnfaktor von solchen Ramschläden, die nehmen, ah, euer Produkt verkauft sich nicht, dann verkaufen wir es. Nee, nee, dann kaufen wir euch alles ab, bevor ihr es überhaupt in die Auslage fällt. Es ist ja eigentlich … Die Welt ist ja … So eine Erpressung. Die Welt ist ja noch viel schlimmer als diese Läden, weil diese Läden ist ja auf eine Art, ah, Dinge verkaufen sich nicht sich nicht, hier sind sie billiger, alle können sie kaufen.
Aber das ist ja nicht wie, es ist ja quasi noch die schöne Seite.
Die schlimme Seite ist zum Beispiel Lacoste, die mal, da gab es mal eine argentinische Punkband, die angefangen hat, auf der Bühne Lacoste zu tragen.
Aber es war so eine Arbeiterklasse-Punkband und die hatten Angst, dass die jetzt Lacoste die Marke beschmutzen, also haben die die angerufen und denen Geld gegeben, damit sie aufhören Lacoste zu tragen. Damit sie Gucci tragen oder so einen Konkurrenten tragen. Aber das fand ich so, das ist doch, alles ist weird, alles ist verschoben, es geht nur noch darum. Vor allem, ich habe schon Magnum Sun Chaser genannt als Produkt, das verkauft wird, und ich habe nichts gegen Magnum. Nee, das macht aber das doch viel spannender, dass du Magnum vor die Karren wirfst, dass du Magnum unter den Bus wirfst, aber alle anderen Firmen schützen willst. Das ist gegen Magnum. Ich habe nichts gegen Magnum. Ist es? Ich bin Langnese-Typ, okay? Ich bin Magnum-Kerl. Ich bin von Anfang an, ich bin in einer Langnesen-Familie aufgewachsen.
Pionette, ich bin jetzt Pionette-Familie. Ich bin in einer Langnesen-Familie aufgewachsen, okay.
Ich bin in einer Lagnese-Familie aufgewachsen. Ich bin in einer Lagnese-Familie aufgewachsen, okay. Ich bin in einer Kellogs, Lagnese-Pepsi, Burger King-Familie aufgewachsen und wir waren immer schon die Underdogs. Wir waren immer die Underdogs, wir wurden immer gemobbt. Aber es ist ein gewisser Stolz, den ich damit verbinde. Und ich werde überall gegen Magnum kämpfen, wo auch immer ich es finde. Leichtes Magnum von Lagnese, ich weiß es nicht. Aber es war ein tolles Erlebnis, weil es diese Waren so ein bisschen entzaubert.
Und ich mir auch denke, wow, so Eis, das ist ja eine Kühlkette, die müssen das kalte Eis irgendwo hinfahren, niemand kauft es.
Und anstatt dass sie sagen, wirf es ins Waschbecken, leg die ins Waschbecken, dann schmelzen die von alleine weg, sagt jemand, nee, nee, pass auf, ich zahle für einen gekühlten Lastwagen, um das in meine Ramschhalle zu fahren, um es dann so billig zu verkaufen und irgendwie springt noch Gewinn raus. Wie billig muss dieses Eis sein? Also ich verstehe es, weil ich bin neulich irgendwie so zu einer Tageszeit an einem Restaurant vorbeigefahren, wo dann so ein, und das ist auch manchmal spannend, so Restaurants, die abends Hightime haben und dann essen da Leute gut und was auch immer und dann fährt man das Tastabelle vorbei und dann kommt dann da auch einfach ein Laster von Rewe und bringt dir Getränke. Und man denkt, ja, klar, auch ein Restaurant holt die Sachen oder Essen, Sachen ja genau da, wo man auch selber vielleicht einkauft.
Egal, und dann war da so ein, kam aber ein Lkw und da stand ganz gross drauf Speiserestentsorgung. Also die haben Öl entsorgt zum Beispiel, weil Öl darf man ja nicht in die Spüle packen, so Fritieröl. Ja, ja, genau. So, und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es viele Produkte in diesem Laden gibt, in diesem Restpostladen, die vielleicht teurer sind, wenn man sie loswerden muss. Ah, verstehe. Es ist gar nicht so leicht, Magnum zu entsorgen, weil das Eis ist ja in der Plastikfolie drin. Müsste man die alle aufmachen, dann ins Waschbecken und dann muss die Stiele … und dann muss man das Gold vom Lithium trennen. Und dann muss jemand die Stiele noch aus dem Waschbecken, die Holzstängel noch ausnehmen. Die kommen nämlich in den Kompost. Die werden verbrannt wiederum, um die Blattgoldmaschine am Laufen zu halten. Also es ist ganz merkwürdig. Und ich habe, wie manche High-End-Produkte trotzdem schmutzend und andersrum. Und ich weiss nicht mehr wohin. Es war für mich eine Woche der Warenentwertung. Was hattest du für eine Woche? Ja, ich habe eine Woche bekommen, wo ich natürlich auch ganz viele Zuschauerinnen Nachrichten gelesen habe. Und wir haben noch eine zweite Stellungnahme, nämlich Florentins Aussage, dass die einzigen Plagen, die es gab in der Bibel, nämlich die Heusschrecken sind.ißt du, was meine Plage ist? Die besserwisserischen Pedanten aus unserer Community. Das sind meine Plage. Das ist mittlerweile eine biblische Plage. Gut, dann kann ich jetzt da sagen, ich habe die Plagen rausgesucht. So. Plage eins. War, weißt du es, kriegst du es hin? Also du hast recht, es gab nicht so viele Tiere, wie man denkt. Aber du hast mich hier lächerlich gemacht mit meiner Aussage, dass Frösche eine Plage waren.
Ich habe dich lange gezogen. Ich dachte, das ist ein Paul-Thomas-Annecen-Film. Nein, Bibel.
Platz eins, also Platz eins für die zehn besten Plagen ist Blut. Hast du recht?
Genere Blut verwandelt. Sieben Tage kein Wasser. Sieben Tage Tage wurde von Mose das Wasser ungenießbar gemacht. Ja, Leute, dann ist das doch viele, oder nicht? Sieben Tage kein Wasser, wer will das überleben?
Oder musst du Blut trinken? Der Niel nur. Ich weiß nicht, umliegend gab es vielleicht noch im Teil der Königin ein bisschen Wohnen. Ja, oder alle mussten zehn Meter flussaufwärts laufen, vor dem Punkt, wo fucking Mose, ich dachte, der war einer der Guten, anscheinend ist ja der Satan, keine Ahnung, was das jetzt hier plötzlich für ein alter Acht ist. Daher bestraft er, bestraft ja, glaube ich, die, ich weiß nicht, was die Menschheit gemacht hat in dem Punkt, ähm, jedenfalls Mose und Aaron taten, wie ihn der Herr geboten hat. Ja, Alter, warum machst du das, du, der, ist nicht das, wenn der, der Gott dir sagt, du, ähm, Mose, pass auf, ich bräuchte einen kurzen Gefallen von dir, ähm, und zwar, ich komme mit der Plage nicht so richtig voran, ähm, und zwar. Alles, ey, ich bin dir noch verschuldig, weil du das mehr geteilt hast für mich. Danke noch mal. Nein, das warst du, das warst du, das war ich nicht. Hör mal auf, nee, das war 80%, du, 20% nicht. Also, ich würde gern, ich hätte Bock, die Wasser zu Blut zu machen, allerdings... Okay. Einfach, nee, einfach mal. Auch in meinem Körper, weil das ist ja schon
aufgegült.
Das ist eine geile Idee. Gut, dass du es sagst.
Das ist eine geile Idee, könnte Plage acht werden
oder irgendwie sowas. Im Körper,
Blut zu Wasser, Wasser zu Blut.
Was war geil, oder?
Einfach mal ausgetauscht.
Geil, schreib mal auf.
Nee, hab nicht zu schreien.
Es dauert ein bisschen Steinmeisen, es dauert sehr lange. Dann mach mal. Also, schau mal auf. Ne, hab nicht zu schade. Das dauert ein bisschen Steinmeißen, das dauert sehr lange.
Dann mach mal. Also, Nil zu Blut. Das Ding ist, ich kann das nicht einfach so lirem larum machen. Ich bräuchte jemanden, der seinen Stock in Fluss hält. Ne, aber allmächtig hast du selber genannt. Also nicht, warum ich meinen Stab. Ich verstehe auch nicht, warum ich einen Stab brauche. Also wenn du einen Menschen brauchst, der dir das Wasser in Blut verwandelt, verstehe ich nicht, warum ich noch meinen göttlichen Stab hochum...
Was machst du doch nicht, Aaron? Warum brauche ich Aaron? Bist du nicht, Aaron ist ein netter Kerl. Ist mein Sohn. Und das habe ich dir aber auch schon gesagt. Ey, der ist ein cooler Typ, dem kannst du gerne mal ein bisschen mehr Zeit mit dem verbringen. Ja, ja, ist ja okay, Jesus. So, also, ähm, pass auf, am Dienstag so gegen 17 Uhr,, halt da bitte gerne mal deinen Stab ins Wasser. Mit meinem Stab meinst du ... Deinen Hirtenstab, hey, Moses, sag mal, Moses, sorry, sorry, ähm, mein Gott, was hat mich auch für Lappen immer. Äh, mach das mal mit dem Stab, äh, und dann mach das. So, und Moses geht zu seiner Frau und sagt, du wirst nicht glauben, was mir heute passiert ist. Ich für Lappen immer. Mach das mal mit dem Stab und dann mach das.
So, und Mose geht zu seiner Frau und sagt, du wirst nicht glauben, was mir heute passiert ist.
Ich halte den Stab ins Wasser und das ganze Wasser wird zu Blut. Oh, das kannst du doch nicht machen, Mose.
Mach das nicht.
Sarah.
Hör mal auf, mach das nicht, sieben Tage kein Wasser.
Scheiss doch, Mose.
Das ist ein bisschen Leidersprechen, die Gord ist allmächtig. Und Gott so, verdammt die flüstern wieder. Aber nee, mach das mal gerade nicht, bitte. Wir haben gerade ein neues Kind bezogen. Ist schon passiert, ich habe ja erzählt, dass es gerade passiert ist, ich mache das eigentlich. Ich wollte meinen Stab in dem Nil halten. Soll ich sieben Tage Blut trinken oder was? Nee, Nil hat woanders. Jetzt ist uns jetzt vorher ein bisschen was eingekauft. Lass uns jetzt noch die Badewanne voll machen, genau. Lass uns jetzt noch die Badewanne voll machen mit Wasser. Mit dem Restrostladen. Ja. Warum macht Mose das? Also das fände ich mal geil, wenn einer in der Bibel sagt so, nee, Alter, das Unmoralische ist es jetzt, dir zu folgen und so. Egal. Wollten die die Ägypter strafen? Weiß ich Äh, jetzt Plage zwei, Frösche. Wow! Frösche. Okay. Frösche wimmeln im Land, und der Herr sprach zu Mose, äh, gern Mose, sage Aaron, sage Aaron, dass er Isaak sagen soll, dass wenn Wenn David fragt, ich was nicht, und der Herr sprach zu Mose, sage Aaron, strecke deine
Hand aus mit deinem Stabe über die Ströme, Kanäle und Sümpfe und lass Frösche über Ägyptenland kommen. Ägyptenland, spannend. Wow. Da sagt man nicht Ägyptenland, Ägyptenland. Ja, so wie Ukrainenland, ja. Deutschen Land. Und Aaron streckte seine Hand aus über die Wasser in Ägypten und es kamen Frösche herauf, sodass Ägyptenland bedeckt wurde. Mit Fröschen. Ich weiss, okay, wir haben irgendwie, die Wahrheit lag wie immer bei uns in der Mitte, die regneten nicht Paul Thomas Anderson-mässig vom Himmel. Eines Naturphänomens, das was regelmässig vorkommt. Regelmässig kommt es sehr selten. Alle zwei Wochen. Ich weiss nicht, hier in Hamburg bin ich selten, vielleicht trägen hier Frösche vom Himmel, in Köln passiert das nicht.
Aber wieder der Stab, was würde passieren, wenn die Menschen einfach sagen würden, hey, lass uns das mal mit den Stäben, weil ehrlich gesagt, so nützlich sind die nicht, wir haben zwei Beine, wir können laufen. Und es ist so Gandalf-Weib.
Ja, warum ist der Staat … oh, das … haben deswegen Zauberer in der moderne Stäbe, weil das der biblischen Vorstellung von Kraft Gottes im Stab? Können wir ja alle zu Hause mal Google fragen. Ja, gut, dass der Stab war und nicht irgendwie so eine Steinschleuder, so ein kleines Y. Und Gandalf hätte dann so ein kleines Mini-Y gehabt als Zeichen der Macht. Wie lame wäre das denn so? So ein kleines Stäbchen, so ein Mini, so ein kleines ... Kleines Zahnstocher. Ja, oder ein Zauberstab. Dritte? Wiedertiere, von wegen Fagin-Holschweigen sind die einzigen, Stechmücken. Stechmücken plagen Mensch und Vieh. Sie taten so, und Aaron reckte seine Hand aus mit seinem Stabe und schlug ihn in Staub auf der Erde, und es kamen Mücken und setzten sich an die Menschen und an das Vieh. Aller Staub der Erde war zu Mücken in ganz Ägyptenland. Was sagt das über die Frösche aus, dass die Frösche ihren Job so schlecht gemacht haben, dass es noch eine Plage gemacht hat? Ich glaub, genau, die finden das geil. Ha, wir Frösche sind anscheinend jetzt keine Plage, so schlimm, dass wir jetzt hier fertig sind und die Faunen wurden zu krass bestraft. Nein, Gott braucht noch ein anderes Nervtier. Ich glaube, der Frosch kommt zu Gott und Gott zu und. Habt ihr das denen richtig gezeigt? Habt ihr das denen richtig gezeigt? Es war so richtig Froschplage, ey. Sie haben uns gestreichelt. Sie haben uns geleckt und haben so wilde Orgien gefeiert. Sie haben an euch geleckt geleckt, was war das denn meistens? Wir sind doch komplett am Ende jetzt, oder was? Es war furchtbar, wir sind darunter und es war eher eine Plage für uns. Also für mich war es eine bisschen Menschenplage. Die haben uns geleckt. Ihr habt gesagt, ihr kriegt das hin mit der Plage, ihr macht die alle, ihr habt gesagt, wir machen die alle, war euer genaue Wortlaut. Dann hat er mich hochgerufen, wo er einfach hat, mir geleckt und dann wurden seine Pupillen so gross. Oh, ey, Alter, ist es da ... Ist nicht schön für uns. Hol mir die Stechmücken. Genau. Aber jetzt vierte Plage ... Wie, um, also ich hätte da lange schon aufgegeben. Vierte Plage. Ich hätte schon nach der ... Es kommen noch sechs danach. Vier, zehn Plagen. Vierte Plage, Stechfliegen. Nee. Stechfliegen füllen alle Häuser. So ein faules Worldbuilding, ey, wirklich. Und der Herr sprach zu Mose, mach dich morgen früh auf und tritt vor den Pharao, Aaron ist offensichtlich raus, Aaron ist raus. Aaron hat es an dem Teil einfach verbockt. Land, auf dem sie wohnen, voller Stechfliegen werden sollen. Können wir eine andere Religion haben, Mama? Können wir nicht doch wieder Juden sein? Vor allem soll er die Pharaonen bestrafen und die Ägypter. Ja, stech nur die. Gott ist sehr unpräzise in seinen Strafen, so kann der nicht einfach nur den stechen. Dann Viehpest, tüttet alle Pferde, Kamele, Rinder und Schafe. Er sprach daher zu Mose, geh hin zum Pharao und sag ihm, so spricht der Herr, der Gott der Hebräer, lass mein Volk ziehen, dass sie mir dienen. Gott, also, ich kann nicht einfach so zum Pharao gehen. Doch, geh hin, geh hin und sage, so spricht der Herr, der Gott der Hebräer, lass mein Volk. Jetzt möchte ich auch einmal was sagen, Gott, weil also dein Scheiß langsam, ich kann nicht einfach so zum Pharao gehen, ich bin ein Schäfer. Was meinst du denn, was der für Gästelisten hat? Hinn? Ich kann nicht, nein, geh, das geht nicht. Und sag. Ich kann nicht einfach so, der Pharao ist der Chef von allem hier. Spricht der Herr, ich bin der Chef. Nein, ja, ich bin Chef und wir gehen da hin. Irrde Schimm, ich kann nicht einfach, soll ich sagen. Nimm deinen Stab, nimm deinen Stab. Ja, okay, okay, alles klar.
Und wenn jetzt der Diener vom Pharao mich fragt, was willst du beim Pharao, was soll ich dann sagen?
Frage bitte, so spricht der Herr, der Gott der Hebräer, lass mein Volk ziehen, dass sie mir dienen, wenn du dich weigerst und sie weiter auffällst, siehe, so wird die Hand des Herrn kommen über dein Vieh auf dem Felde und über die Pferde, Esel, Kamele, Rinder und Schafe mit sehr schwerer Pest. So, und was ist, wenn die Wache dann sagt und mich nicht vorlässt? Also wenn die das macht, also wenn die das bringt, dann kommt die nächste Plage. Schwarze Blattern kommen dann. Ach Gott. auf böse Blattern an den Menschen und am Vieh, so dass die Zauberer nicht vor Mose treten konnten, wegen der bösen Blattern, denn es waren an den Zauberern ebenso böse Blattern wie an Heiliger Gitter. Jetzt war gegen Zauberer? Das erfahren wir jetzt? Ich habe so gehofft, dass sie wird es irgendwann einmal erklären, was das ist, aber stattdessen wiederholen sie immer böse Blattern. Das ist doch auch so ein Martin-Luther-Übersetzungsvergabe, kann ich mir auch malabe, kein Problem. Sieben, Hagel tötet Menschen.
Gott, wir haben Zauberer, warum sprichst du nicht mit denen, was hast du denn hier? Die, Feinde am Zauberer. Ihr tritt vor die und wirf einfach so Staub ins Gesicht. Das ist so eine lame Welt, so eine lame Fantasy-Welt, das würde ja heute niemand mehr durchgehen lassen, so ein Quatsch. Hagel tötet Menschen und Vieh, zerstört Ernte und Bäume, da sprach der Herr zu Mose,
räche seine Hand aus gen Himmel und wink mir, das ist Hagel über ganz Ägyptenland, über Menschen, über Vieh und über alles Gewächs auf dem Feld in Ägyptenland. Acht Heuschrecken, dann wirklich er hat seinen Trumpf, Heuschrecken bedecken das Land und fressen alles grün, da sprach der Herr zu M, das Heuschrecken auf die Gippen gekommen. Der Hagel hat doch eh schon das meiste zerstört. Hagel sollte doch auch schon Pflanzen und Bäume zerstören.
Es wird literally gesagt, alles auffressen, was im Lande wächst, alles, was der Hagel übrig gelassen hat.
Kleine Kritik am Hagel auch, ne? Alles, was der Hagel nicht kaputt gemacht hat.
Sorry, fuck Hagel, ey. Sorry. Wieder, das kommt so oft, Hagel. Hagel kommt nur noch ganz selten. Jetzt Finsternis. Neun ist Finsternis. Dauert drei Tage. Da sprach der Herr zu Mose, rechelt deine Hand aus gen Himmel, dass ein solche Finsternis werde in Ägyptenland, dass man sie greifen kann. Ich denke, in der Zeit, wo Gott ihm das alles sagt, hätte er das ja alles selber machen. Ja, locker. Warum muss er mal Mose gen Himmel recken? Zehntens Tod aller Erstgeborenen und von Mensch und Vieh. Und Mose sprach, so spricht der Herr, um Mitternacht will ich durch Ägyptenland gehen und alle Erstgeburt in Ägyptenland soll sterben vom ersten Sohn des Pfarrer Ohren, der erst am Thron sitzt, bis hin zum Sohn der Magd, die hinter der ihrer Mühe hockt, und alle Erstgeburt unter dem Vieh. Ich will damit nur sagen, es gab mehrere Tiere. Und Blattern vielleicht, und oder Tier, oder Blattern, Feen, Wesen, weiss man nicht genau, Asche, Fee oder so. Die Heuschrecken wirken auf eine Art wie, weil sie eben die J Ernte auffressen und das Land verwüsten. Aus dem Leben gegriffen so ein bisschen, ne? Mehr jetzt als die Frösche, die regnen. Die Frösche sind die einzigen, die einfach wegen ihrer Art bestraft. Also ihr seid eklig, bitte. Ja, aber wird wirklich von dem Frosch Regen gesprochen? Einfach nur Frösche überall. Frösche überall. Frogs überall. Frösche sind überall jetzt. Ich glaube, ich werde auch Opfer einer Plage, und zwar, ich habe grosse Schwierigkeiten mit Ladegeräten. Also ich habe bei jedem Ladegerät Wackelkontakt. Ja, wir wissen das seit Jahren. Dass ihr überhaupt schon mal ein Video von uns gesehen haben könntet, allein ist irgendwie so ein Wunder. Ja, das ist dein Wunder. So ein Segen, so ein Sankt-Stefan. Ich habe überall, alle meine Ladegeräte haben direkt Wackelkontakt, ich muss immer mein Handy Was machst du denn irgendwo hinlegen, damit dann auch noch ein Widerstand und irgendwas gegen ein Ladegerät drückt. Ich glaube, ich bin verflucht. Und Gott sprach zu Mose, regge deine Hand Richtung Ägyptenland und lass, seitdem du in Ägypten warst, und lass alle Menschen Probleme haben mit ihren Ladegeräten. Ohne Witz, ich hätte die Ägypter in zwei Tagen in die Knie gezwungen, wenn du sagst, alle elektronischen Geräte haben Wackelkontakt beim Laden. So, viel Spaß. Nach 15 Minuten kommen die an, sorry, welches Volk sollten wir nochmal ziehen lassen? Was war die Forderung nochmal? Welches Volk sollten wir genau nochmal, die wären sofort am Ende. Das ist das Schlimmste, was es gibt. Wenn du so ein Handy hast mit acht Prozent und du denkst, ich muss gleich los und es lädt nicht und lädt dann nur kurz und du lässt es liegen, kommst zurück und merkst, es hat nicht gebacken Laden, weil es einfach Quatsch ist. Ich liebe diesen Moment, wo man rausgeht, irgendwie vor die Tür gehen muss und man hat vergessen, das Handy zu laden.
Und dann mache ich immer das Handy ran, gehe nochmal auf Toilette oder so oder gehe nochmal durchs Haus, wie ist die Fenster und dann bitte ich, es war so zehn Sekunden dran und ich gehe raus damit. Das ist so dumm. Aber man macht das, weil man denkt, das bringt noch. Wie viel Strom geht da rein? Nichts. Geht das nicht schneller? Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Ganz furchtbar. Ich wünsche euch keine Plagen. Falls ihr Plagen habt, meldet euch. Vielleicht müsst ihr irgendwas ziehen lassen oder so. Alter, das wäre mehr Geld. Ich brauche noch ein Wunder. Angeblich, ich bin immer schon bei mir, ich habe schon mehr geleistet. Ich brauche noch für meine Heilig-Sprechung ein Wunder. Genau, wir haben ja ein Stein im Brett beim neuen Papst, weil wir haben ja... Leo. Leo, genau, wir haben ja ein bisschen mitgeholfen, den zu pushen. Du redest in der nächsten Folge drüber. Genau, ich habe in Peru viel Arbeit geleistet.
Wir haben einige Fäden gezogen.
Und vielleicht hast du jetzt ein Stein im Brett, tatsächlich zu Sankt Stephan zu werden.
Deswegen meine ich, also wenn ihr eine Plage nämlich habt und ich befreie euch von der Plage,
löse euch davon, wäre das vielleicht ein gutes Wunder, was man irgendwie einreichen könnte.
Finde ich gut. Schreibt uns gerne, ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste Woche wieder.
Wir sehen uns, hören uns, macht's gut.
Bis dahin, macht's gut. Tschüss, wir heben ab,
eh ihr hier rein.
It's the worst bird production. Booking.com buchst du dein Ferienhaus ganz einfach. Und dank kostenloser Stornierung passiert das hier nicht mehr.
Wird das gebucht, Leute? Oh, Mark und Tim kommen jetzt.
Bei Booking.com kannst du kostenlos stornieren. Oh, so einfach.
So geht's problemlos von zu Hause ins Ferienhaus.
Hab eine grössere Unterkunft gebucht.
Auf Booking.com findest du dein Ferienhaus ganz einfach.
Und einfach entspannen.
Booking.com, Booking.yeah.
Überprüfe vor der Buchung die Stornierungsrichtlinie der Unterkunft.